when we think of iconic heroes
throughout all kinds of pathology there
is always one that comes to mind one
that most people will be familiar with
regardless of whether they've heard his
stories or even though of Greek
mythology you may know him best by his
Greek name Heracles or the Roman
iteration Hercules but he was best known
as the last mortal son of Zeus a nearly
man to be born from a mortal woman to
become a god upon his death Heracles his
mother was the mortal woman
alchemy named Anne according to Homer's
Iliad when Zeus had learnt of her
pregnancy he announced all of his fellow
gods are on this given day a child of
Zeus would be born into the house of
Perseus who would become the high king
and rule all those around him Zeus his
wife Hera had him taken oath swearing at
his world would come true and upon doing
so she descended from Olympus and
traveled to Argos where she found the
wife of Sten Ella's a son of Perseus
Hera made its Austin Alice's son would
be born premature but on the same day as
you expected Heracles to be born she
also attempted to stop al Kamini from
giving birth to Herakles and his twin
brother epic Lee's she had one of Al
Khomeini's servants Gail and this
lighter Elly Thea the goddess of
childbirth telling her that alchemy Nia
had already given birth to her sons
ilithyia was not fooled by this trickery
and rushed to up Kamini scient allowing
her two sons to be born
this meant that Zeus's oath would be
fulfilled but it was still known as his
son Eurystheus who would become the
great ruler and not Heracles alchemy a
feared that Hera will take revenge upon
her off the Harun off the birth of
Heracles so she gave her son away he
would eventually be taken to Olympus
where he was raised by Hera and his
half-sister Athena who appeared in
numerous stories involving Heracles
often protected and aid in the Hara Hara
not recognizing their child nursed him
out of pity
but Heracles suckle so strongly that
Hera pushed him away in pain the ancient
Greeks and Romans believed that Hera's
milk sprayed across the heavens and
formed the Milky Way
it was also through Harris divine milk
that Heracles acquired his supernatural
powers
Athena would eventually bring Heracles
back to his parents when he was a young
infant and he was given the name
al-qaida's the boy was only renamed to
Heracles as an attempt to appease Hera
who retaliated by sending two giant
snakes into the children's chamber the
snake circle difficulys causing the
infant to cry out in fear but Heracles
protecting his brother grabbed the snake
in each hand and strangled them when the
two were later found playing with the
giant snakes as if they were toys
Heracles as parents sent for the blind
prophet Tiresias who prophesize an
unusual future for the boy telling them
that he would vanquish many fierce and
deadly monsters the actions of Hera in
this story seemed to be mostly driven
out of spite and disdain for Zeus who
despite having many children both God
and mortal seemed exceedingly proud and
hopeful of Heracles you'll soon find
that Haris feelings of anger and hate
towards Zeus transferred themselves to
Heracles as she attempted to destroy
what she saw as one of Zeus's price
creations it was a long after his birth
that Heracles began to develop a
reputation as the strongest of all
mortals with some even seen a demigod as
possessing a level of strength that not
even the gods could match his
exceptional physical abilities were
somewhat offset by a rather noticeable
lack of intelligence and wisdom what
many considered to be his major weakness
by no means am I saying that Heracles
was a complete idiot but sometimes his
lack of rational thinking and strong
emotions would often lead him into
troublesome situations there is a story
where Heracles became so incensed by how
high the temperature was that he pulled
out his bow and threatened to shoot the
son it became quite common for Greek
playwrights to portray him in a comical
manner almost as this large muscular
buffoon but even in some of the more
serious writings of critics and poets
Heracles was shown as a primitive and
extremely violent man his weapon of
choice was a massive Club and he would
wear the skin of a lion almost created
in this caveman like hunter-gatherer
persona
despite his many floors Heracles would
often help those in need
many of his greatest deeds and
adventures occurred during his 12 labors
a series of stories that cover the
penance and redemption that made
Heracles the hero we know today as
Heracles his reputation grew so did the
resentment that Hera felt towards him he
was a living example of her husband's
infidelities he would eventually marry
the daughter of King Creon Megara and
after witnessing how loved Heracles was
by all those around him she wants again
interfered driving the hero into a fit
of insanity and anger in which he killed
his wife and children once he had calmed
down he realized what he had done and
felt deep regret knowing that his crimes
would most likely go unpunished he
traveled to the Oracle of Delphi where
he would ask for forgiveness he was told
that he could atone for his actions by
serving Eurystheus who had become King
in place of Heracles but what Heracles
did not know is that the Oracle of
Delphi was being guided by Hera
initially he was also carry out 10
labors but this number would later rise
to 12 as King Eurystheus refused to
count the Aegean stables and the slain
of the Hydra as part of his labors given
the hero two additional Labor's to carry
out the very first labor given to
Heracles was in the maeín lion an
enormous lion that plagued the district
of Nemea the Lions hide was extremely
thick and impervious to weapons made
from any kind of metal there are tales
of the lion taken women as hostages back
to its lair Lorin warriors from
surrounding towns into its cave when
they came across the women the lion
would pounce tearing him into pieces
with his razor-sharp claws I could cut
through armed with ease Heracles knew
when he entered its cave that no weapon
would aid him he would have to wrestle
the lion and after a long grueling
confrontation
Heracles was eventually able to
overpower the lion strangling it with
his bare hands
he would then use one of the Lions claws
to skin its hide creating the hero's
iconic armor when he returned to
Eurystheus the King seen the Lions hide
instantly feared that it was now roaming
the streets of his City when he finally
realized that it was indeed our hero
wearing the hide he then informed
Heracles that his second labor would be
the Linnaean Hydra Bravo cousin I see
the Nemean lion was no match for the
mighty Heracles but I assure you your
next task shall not be so easy
the people of Learner have been
terrorized for years by the Hydra
travelled to that godforsaken Lake and
end their misery the Hydra of learning
was a nine headed water serpent that
roamed the swamps of Lake Learner
it was also raised by Hera with the sole
purpose of one day killing Heracles for
this task Ares enlisted the help of his
nephew lola's and when the two
eventually tracked down the Beast they
found themselves in a swamp covered in a
thick layer of poisonous mist and
radiated from the hydras mouth the to
cover their faces with several layers of
cloth and began to fire flaming arrows
to law the Hydra from its lair when the
Beast emerged Pericles charged drawing
his sword and chopping off one of its
many heads but to the heroes shocked two
heads grew back in its place
every time he chopped off one of its
heads once again two grew back in its
place not knowing what to do Heracles
turned to Lola's who suggested they used
fire when Heracles cut off one of the
monster's heads
Lola's would take his firebrand and
cauterized the wound may concern' new
heads could not grow from the stump seen
that her monsters lose in the battle
Hera sent a giant crab to aid the Hydra
but it served as little more than a
distraction as it was easily crushed by
Heracles when Heracles and lowness had
finally found the hydras one immortal
head he took a golden sword that had
been given to him by Athena and using
the sword the technique of cauterize in
the wound they were finally able to kill
the monster
but before he left Heracles dipped his
arrows in the hydras poisonous blood
thinking they may prove useful in future
Labor's upon returning to King
Eurystheus he was very displeased of the
amount of help that Heracles received
during this labor and refused to count
it as successful my my my cousin it
appears you have quite the talent for
slaying monsters but do your skills
extend to tracking them I wonder bring
me the sarony in hind that is if you can
find the animal of course the third
labor of Heracles was this Iranian hind
both King Eurystheus and Hera were
angered by Heracles completion of the
previous two Labour's and so they
constructed a house that they believed
would be the end of Heracles the tasks
did not involve the killing of a beast
but instead the capture of one viscera
nyan hind was believed to be so fast
that it could outrun an arrow our hero
chase the animal on foot across all of
Greece for an entire year and when he
eventually did capture the animal the
goddess Artemis was not pleased with the
treatment of one of her favorite
creatures Eurystheus had hoped that
chasing the Beast would invoke Artemis's
fury but after pleading with the goddess
she agreed to let Heracles take the hind
back on the one condition that it was
returned to the wild once the task was
finished when Heracles took the hind
back to King Eurystheus he was told that
it will be added to his menagerie having
promised to return the hind he agreed
that he would only hand it over if the
king came and collected it himself when
the king appeared
Heracles led the hind go and it lept
into the air sprint him back to its
mistress Heracles laughed and remarked
that the king must not have been quick
enough embarrassed and upset that
Heracles had completed another labor he
demanded that the hero bring back the
erymanthian boar which leads us to the
full flavor of Heracles the erymanthian
boar much like many of the beasts that
Heracles had already faced the
erymanthian boar was a large and
extremely dangerous creature that
ravaged a farm land in western arcadia
he was advised by the Centaur Chiron to
chase the boar into the fix
where would be most vulnerable he then
trapped the ball in a large net and took
it back to King Eurystheus who was so
afraid when he saw the beast he lept
into a pythor's jaw demanding that
Heracles leave and take the beast with
him not all tasks the glorious battles
with monstrous creatures Heracles king
will jeaious visitor the largest stay
banila of greece and it's in need of
spring cleaning you can frown all you
like but that is your task now go v
labor that Heracles would have to face
was the cleaning of the stables all
joyous ojs was a king known for his
enormous herd of cattle that were
considered divine and immortal and as a
result they produce an enormous amount
of dung Pericles was ordered to clean or
dress his stables which housed over
3,000 cattle and had not been cleaned in
30 years
in this task Heracles proved himself to
be rather resourceful as he reroute the
rivers of Alphaeus and Pinellas to wash
away all the filth from the stable the
king had promised Hercules a portion of
his cattle if he could finish the job in
one day so he surprised an anger when he
saw Heracles do so he refused to honor
their agreement
Heracles would like to kill the king and
give his kingdom - or jeaious his son
phyleus who had previously been exiled
for siding with Heracles during his
father's disagreement once again
Heracles returned to Eurystheus who did
not count the laborers finished because
the water had done the cleaning for
Heracles and because he attempted to
take payment for his service you still
have seven labors to complete Heracles
returned to me once you've defeated the
birds of stem failure least in failure
birds were a flock of man-eaters that
had been trained by the God of War Ares
wherever they swarmed crops were
destroyed and the townspeople fled
Heracles located them in the masters of
lake stem failure but he could not reach
their nests as the soft marshland could
not support his weight seeing her
brother's plight Athena
appeared to Heracles and gave him a
rattle and incra taller that had been
made by Hephaestus for this task
when Heracles shook the rattle the birds
are woke from their slumber and flew
into their air
where Herakles would shoot them with the
arrows that he had dipped in the
poisonous spell of the Hydra the ones he
could not kill flew away and never
returned to Arcadia they made a new home
on the island of aretaeus where Jason
and the Argonauts will encounter them
later
still alive I see cousin sail to Crete
and bring me the chrétien bull for your
seventh labor and so Heracles sailed to
Crete and asked King Minos if he could
take the bull the king willingly
accepted as it had been causing havoc
all over Crete the boss sent back to
King Eurystheus we was kept in a cage it
would eventually break free from this
cage and head into the town of Marathon
what would cause more chaos until it
would be killed by the hero Theseus
why do you look so smug Heracles does
only a bull your next task is far more
challenging travels of Thrace and bring
me the mares of Diomedes Heracles is
eighth labor was to steal the horses
that belong to King Diomedes the
barbaric king of Thrace and the son of
Ares he had managed to breed man-eating
horses they were wild and uncontrollable
and their diet of human flesh only made
their behavior worse
Heracles knowing that this task would
not be easy took several companions with
him and when they captured the horses
the king and his men began their pursuit
in an attempt to reclaim their price
deeds in order to fight the king
Heracles left his most trusted companion
at Baris in charge of the horses when he
returned he found that the boy had been
eaten Heracles was so angry that he fed
Diomedes to his own horses on the
journey back Heracles bound them out as
the horses shut calming them and taken
them back to King Eurystheus who in some
versions sacrificed him to Harrow and in
others allowed them to roam freely in
August now that they were permanently
calm
you had aid once again Herakles but as
you are in mourning for that peasant boy
your task is complete
only four more to go I take it you're
familiar with Hippolyta the Amazonian
Queen well her father Ares gave her a
magical girdle retrieve it for me and
your ninth labor shall be complete once
his ship had reached the island of the
Amazons
Hippolyta was so impressed by the feats
that Heracles had performed that she
agreed to give him her girdle Heracles
invited the Queen to a meal back on his
ship where they could share stories of
one another the Queen eagerly accepted
but Harold once again interfered
disguising herself as one of the Amazon
women and spreading rumors that Heracles
plan to abduct their queen
the Amazons decided that they would
confront Heracles when he saw them
approaching he assumed that Hippolyta
had set up an ambush and had no
intention in letting them leave the
island
Heracles unsure of what to do next ended
up killing the Queen and taken her
girdle he ordered his men to set so
immediately before the Amazons were
aware of what had happened you seem to
be making quite an enemy of Ares I'd be
careful if I were you Heracles you may
not live to complete your labors the
giant Geryon
has a herd of glistening cattle like
I've never seen before they would make a
fine addition to my collection say Otto
his Island and bring me them for
Heracles his tenth labor
he was also still the cattle of the
giant Gary on whose herd was described
as being stained red by the light of the
sunset in order to reach Gary on on the
Island of Airy Thea Heracles had to
cross the Libyan desert where he became
so frustrated by the heat that he fired
an arrow at the Sun Helios rather than
anger helios showed admiration for the
courage of Heracles and gave him his
golden chariot to cross the desert with
soon as Hercules landed on array Thea he
was confronted by authoress two-headed
dog with one huge swing of his club
Heracles killed the watchdog the
herdsmen came to assist authors but
Heracles dealt with him in the same way
having heard the commotion the joint
confronted Heracles
garyun was described as a three-body
giant with four pairs of wings but
Heracles was in no way phase by the
strange appearance of Gary on the giant
followed in the same footsteps as
authors in the herdsman falling victim
to her at Lisa's Club he led the cattle
onto the ship and set sail back to
Eurystheus well that is now attend
Labour's complete but you still have two
more go to the garden of the Hesperides
and bring back some of those golden
apples that the gods protect so dearly
the garden of asperities contained
golden apples that have been given to
Hera from Gaia as a wedding present it
was guarded by the Hesperides as well as
the serpent laid on in some variations
of the tale
Heracles tricked the Titan Atlas into
retrieve an apples for him and then
others Heracles charged into the garden
slain laden and retrieve an apples
himself with only one labor left
Eurystheus inherit began to accept that
Heracles might earn the forgiveness that
he desired and so they gave him one last
task one that they felt was impossible
for most gods and any mortal your
redemption is almost upon us Heracles
the underworld has always fascinated me
travel to the gates of Hades and bring
me back its three-headed Guardian
Cerberus Heracles travelled to the
underworld of both Hermes and Athena
guiding him and when he eventually
reached the gates that were guarded by
Cerberus he was told by Athena that
taken Cerberus without the permission of
Hades will not end war for the hero and
so Heracles travelled to the underworld
where he would come face the face of
Hades he explained that he needed his
assistance
Hades did not reject his request instead
he told him that he could borrow
Cerberus on one condition
he would have to subdue the giant
three-headed hound without harming him
with no other option Heracles began
wrestling with Cerberus as Hades eagerly
watched on when Heracles eventually
overpowered the Hound he promised the
Hades that he would return Cerberus once
his labors had ended
when he returned victorious carrying
Cerberus Eurystheus once again jumped
into his jaw your Labor's are complete
and your sins are absolved now leave and
take that beast back to the underworld
Heracles had finally completed his epic
journey that spanned over many years he
had come to terms with his horrendous
actions and he now felt he could move on
without the constant guilt of his crimes
haunting him not long after he joined
jason and the argonauts in their quest
for the golden fleece and he would
eventually remarry but his wife's
jealousy would also mean lead to his
death as she covered his clothing in a
love potion made from the blood of the
Hydra which would cause the hero to die
a painful death having seen the great
deeds that his son performed Zeus made
it so Heracles would rise to an impasse
and finally earned the status of God
Heracles was destined to become the
greatest ruler of all time but because
of Hera's actions in spite he instead
became the greatest Greek hero of all
time and I would dare to say the most
iconic figure in the entirety of Greek
mythology growing up I've always been
fond of Heracles ever since I sold a
Disney movie but you never really
understand what motivates the character
until you read about his early life and
his 12 labors everyone loves a good
redemption story and Heracles is no
different I know this has been an
extremely requested video and Heracles
features in so many stories that they're
most likely will be several more videos
covering the hero feel free to share
your opinions and thoughts on Heracles
with me in the comments below as always
I've been your host mythology and
fiction explained